all right here we go I'm going to talk
about output compressing randomized
encoding and its application so it's a
very natural progression as you've seen
this morning and I'll tell you what they
are okay so randomized encoding we're
seeing it's a very beautiful concept
that we want to encode a single
computation a complex one into a simpler
computation and here i want to stress
two points one is a single competition
what does that mean is that the encoding
government needs to take both a
deterministic program which we can think
of as either representing a circuit or
in a tool emotion together with the
input so once these two things are
specified this computation is really
determined there is no like wiggle room
or any changes so it's a single
computation and after encoding it we
want to say that and satisfy the
simplicity requirement what does that
mean is that it's actually much simpler
to compute the encoding to encode the
computation than actually performing the
computation itself and yet still of
course there is no free lunch it cannot
be that the encoding becomes much easier
and we don't have to pay the time for
computing the function anymore so we
still have to pay but these payment is
somehow delayed at the time of decoding
only at the decoding time to actually
get the output of the computation we
have to run as long as or where the
competition will have to be as complex
as the original computation and
additionally this encoding is to satisfy
some security requirement in particular
it needs to hide the most emotion and
the input so for this talk it will be
convenient sometimes to just think about
this machine and input and some machine
that has the input hard-coded inside so
it's a machine that takes no input at
all and in particular for the purpose of
this talk I'm going to examine more
closely with a simplicity and security
me so simplicity as have been mentioned
in the literature mostly means low
parallel
time complexity or it means low depth
computation and buy this beautiful
theorem by an upper bound Cheyenne
couche Levitt and says that any store
kids polynomial time circuit can
actually be encoded in c0 in constant
parallel time and really a beautiful
concept and has found many many
applications to different topics in
crypto for example MPC parallel crypto
verifiable delegation and I want to
mention that somehow randomized the
encoding especially low depth randomized
encoding it's very closely related with
couple circuits but for some reason it
really kind of because this concept
itself stresses on the simplicity of the
encoding it really brings forward the
low depth of the encoding algorithm to
the spotlight and for some reason this
gives a very simple and powerful
abstraction and they enabled a lot of
thought process that was not there
before when we're just thinking about
gobble circuit and I think that's really
the beauty of randomized encoding and of
course there's no particular reason to
focus to say simplicity has two equals
to load apps we can think about other
measures of simplicity in fact they
exist in the literature and today I'm
going to focus only on one of them in
particular it's called simply low
encoding time I just want the time to
encode the computation to be much much
smaller than the time to actually
perform it and the first observation we
should make is that if I want this then
I cannot think about circuit
representation I must think about the
truly motion representation because
otherwise encoding algorithm to even
just read the entire circuit were strong
were run as long as the time of the
computation and what I want is really
given a very short truly machine the
description is small together with a
short input and for simplicity let me
just think about the total length of
them is something bounded by polynomial
in the security perimeter I want to say
that the encoding algorithm were created
encoding important on your time
independent of the running time of the
Turing machine alternatively you
view it as could depend only polar
logarithmically on the running time of
the tool emotion and this seems like a
very magic and very powerful thing and
nonetheless in a recent line of work we
show that we can actually achieve that
assuming very strong assumption which is
sub expansion I 0 and 1 wave function
and by now you must be saying of course
magic implies magic indeed a good point
but nevertheless I'm gonna consider even
more magic in this talk one with
functions of the first one is even
better point I like that so 16 to
randomize the encoding as also near was
talking about it's really a very
powerful primitive now let's just look
at it a little bit think about it for
five seconds we get this very short
representation of this computation the
encoding algorithm rounds pouring on
your time in the lens of the description
in other words it cannot in any way
attempt to try to compute this function
at all it must have taken the
description bit by bit at this and
produce this encoding to hide it yet the
encoding need to be able to produce the
entire output so since that it's really
kind of something optimal is the case
it's not a case there's a caveat until
your kind of look deeply into those
recent works is that they were
considered boolean tool emotion boolean
Turing machine nan Bullen Turing machine
why do I care it's without loss of
generality why because if I take a
general tuning machine with lon output I
can just think about encoding those
bully and tone emotions that outputs
each output bid one at a time and if I
can call them separately I can apply
this 16 two randomized encoding except
that now the time for encoding worse
kill linearly with the length of the
output so that it's not so optimal
anymore why because well there could
exist at or emotion that outputs its
output is say a constant fraction of its
running time and that means that the
randomized encoding or the entire
encoding is over have to be even longer
so there's room to even improve it and
this is the focus of this work we want
to look at whether we can have output
compressing randomized encoding in other
words I wonder can we encode a
computation in time that's even showed
shorter than its output okay and for
general non boolean Turing machines
we're going to call this randomized
encoding a call randomized encoding
compact if the encoding time mr.
polynomial independent of running time
and the output lines or I can consider
slightly weaker notion which we call
sublinear randomized encoding where the
encoding were still skill always running
time but polynomially with the sub
linear polynomial dependency ok so with
such efficiency requirement now you can
see that there really exist to those
tooling machine competition where the
output is really really long an input in
particular the output is going to be
much much longer than encoding itself
that could exist with there could also
it is the tuning machine which is just
boolean then there is no the encoding is
going to be longer but there could exist
a total immersion that outputs really
long string and the output is going to
be longer than encoding itself that's
why the name output compressing all
right so this sounds like even more
magic why not we can do such thing to my
now to compact array and
they just want to make sure was succeed
missed means the scaling with the rent
with doubtful and compact means a dozen
scale or skill sub linearly with the
output less likely if you're comparing
your deafness accents but Sabrina argue
is something that's on the side all
right William during machines if I step
on Tiffany what your old compaq can
succeed this is identical thank bed is
just so you're trying to separate
boolean on Memorial or something dark
like full on Julian is about definitions
I mean according to me boolean they are
the same before entering merchants
succinct the compact means the same
thing because output is only one bit
however phone number and Turing machine
succinct randomized encoding is going to
grow with the length of the output
whereas compact randomized encoding the
lines were not girl with the length of
the output one particular construction
but but if a nice definition is the same
so if i write the definition I don't
talk about boolean there is only the
only to grow in comfort done it's not
like we already in the following form
such think two means the wrong time is a
poll a in security parameter log of
running time and length of the output
compact means pull a in n log of T
without the output yeah
say office kitchen because interesting
about the log output is like a truth
table and your guy right I'm going to go
into it yeah all right so do do people
now agree this is something stronger
than six inked a randomized encoding
okay great so let me move on i have lots
of slides alright so first the thing is
that wait a minute this thing is very
nice but how about security we want
security after all immediately you were
noticed in the length of the encoding is
smaller than the if the encoding is
shorter than outputs there's no way that
we can hope to get simulation based
security why because I can think about
the output as something that is
incompressible like a pseudo random
string then a simulator can not compress
this to the random string into a short
encoding that we expanded to it
therefore it is necessary that we have
to look at other types of security
notion in particular
indistinguishability based ones what's
the most natural way the first thought
that comes into mind well we call it
weak indistinguishability security is
that if I have a pair of computation and
they have the same output identical
output and for now let me just think
about both of the machines where I have
the same running time upper bound then I
want to encoding to be indistinguishable
a very natural weakening of the
simulation based security and as you can
guess since I'm calling this the week
indistinguishability security so there
must be a stronger one okay the standard
one that we also study in this paper is
called the distributional
indistinguishability security what it
requires is that what if I don't want
the output to be exactly identical I
want to say relax a little bit to see
the output are only indistinguishable to
each other then I still want the
encoding to be indistinguishable
exactly so no no side information okay
just the output so wait since I know
right the Turing machine let me get into
that in that could so first of all as a
nice pointing out the first thing is
that those motions are deterministic
what does it mean that output during
distinguishable they're either equal not
equal okay so therefore that's why it's
called a distributional the machines are
sampled themselves from two
distributions and when their sample from
the distribution and evaluate it maybe
they give indistinguishable output okay
seems like also and meaningful
definition to consider yeah yeah M prime
X prime thank you you close also
consider the randomized mmm yes how does
it relate to that if i consider random
meister m it would be a different notion
and in particular i don't know whether
it's implied by simulation security on
the other hand this notion which
consider deterministic about
distribution on machines it's actually
implied by simulation security casual as
an ocean itself it seems more reasonable
okay but the power of it I suspect is
very similar with consider a randomized
am
coding should allow you to sample this
you could consider two randomized
emotions that have the property that
when you run them they produce the lega
two distributions basically encoding
will Allah it's yeah it's complicated
i'm not defining it as a matter of fact
i'm defining the distribution on and
good the reasons why didn't go that
route okay alright so when these weaker
security notion now the question come
back alive can compact or selenia are
you exist and even before we go there
and than the fact that it seems like a
natural extension over successor ones i
want to note that there is actually a
very natural kind of relation between a
fascination and randomized in cody and
to see this connection allow me to now
go to a higher level of abstraction
without thinking about whether is
tooling machine or circuits compact or
16th to so and so forth this look at
these two notions of rank above high so
first question is about encoding a
computation but still allow it allow us
to use a multiple times by evaluating a
lot of input whereas randomized the
encoding is really a long time used
because input is fixed so in some sense
you can be randomized encoding as kind
of a degenerated I vacation how do I
degenerate it I fixed input or you could
equivalently think about our he is a
fascination for those two emotion that
have no input at all therefore or we
aren't always like a different notions
of security for randomized encoding
nicely corresponds to security notions
of fascination for example the
indistinguishability security the week
one correspond 112 indistinguishability
investigation whereas the stimulation
security will correspond one to one with
the BBB of a station so the natural
question is is there a correspondence
with this distributional version
actually there is
they were corresponding to what we call
a puncture Belial don't think about it
and your notion is just a way to
understand the different notions what is
a puncture bio it's basically I 0
whereas I always afford those machines
that are completely functionally
equivalent but puncture y 0 is photos
machine that are equivalent everywhere
except to one point and on that point
the outputs are indistinguishable so
this is nature has been used again and
again in our applications of I oh this
is closely related with this puncture
the program paradigm and as a high and
water is shown in their beautiful work
that four circuits puncture bio and IO
are the same thing and if you look at
puncture bio energy generated by fixed
one input you get precisely the
distribution notion of
indistinguishability security okay yes
is no let's not know that i put x is
known x is something everybody knows
it's a public machine so we've been
wonderful pets is indistinguishable from
us or pads then as a equal minute but
there's some point of our distribution
but access the examples of Earth's axis
fix X is fixed yes but the machine are
not fixed machine our sample from the
distribution they just disagree on one
point I see answer machine so has this
amazing abilities a machines also to
tosa machines are not opposite is some
secret randomness oh sorry some secret
randomization for the outputs and of
course isn't the other little bit yeah
Ramona comparing output distribution
without the machines otherwise it's
easily distinguishable yeah alright so
this is kind of a nice comparison
between the station and randomized
encoding and this comparison holds if i
consider both circuit representation in
both sides as well as if i consider
truly machine representation at both
sides so if I think about Julie machine
investigation they will correspond
precisely nicely with our compactor are
you okay and therefore now
we can play around with it we already
know that simulation-based compact are
you can you exist because encoding is
too short so equivalently words already
no way before that vvb Fortuna motion
the negatives through a very simple
counterexample quite functional Teresa
this distributional thing because you
can just basically think about the only
input for m1 m2 is X by fixing by fixing
the input affects the info to be X I
think about the two machines that are
zero everywhere else except on racks and
all X yeah
alright so for i 0 because we know I
offer 20 motion exist therefore
degenerated you were already known
compact are you is weak
indistinguishability security also
exists that's good news we know some
kind of compactness can exist if you're
believing I all but so far I don't know
whether this distributional version
would exist or not it's a slightly
stronger notion which sits between
something which is impossible and
something that is possible I don't know
where it will go on the other hand
perhaps are even bigger problem more
ambitious problem is that well I always
kind of a very degenerated version of
randomized income is a very degenerative
version but is it possible that this I
can go from the degenerative version to
the full of escalation some arrow from
the other side okay so in this work
surrounding the first question of
possibility and impossibility we shall
both positive and negative result on one
hand if we just assume some exponential
malfunction turns out that compact are
ye I'm going to assume by default it has
the distribution of indistinguishability
security cannot exist for general
distributions and want to point out the
first impossibility assumes much
stronger assumption and it was pointed
out to us by NIR Biton ski and the omer
piness and then later we we can do the
assumption to sub exponents of
exponential one we function only so in
particular it doesn't have a consequence
with this comparison with io it means
that puncture bio for tuning machine do
not exist for general distribution and
instead if we're puncturing a program
and somehow the output is
indistinguishable on the puncture the
point then your program has to be as
long as the output cannot be shorter in
an output generally solutions be
officially simply the distributions like
yes and the next is that nevertheless we
still want a possibility so to get
possibility we need to circumvent
impossibility means that either I have
to leave the nice word of the plane
model which we do show that if I
consider a crs model then actually
functional encryption full power
function encryption will give us this
compact or sublinear re in the crs model
and in fact in the crs model we can't
even get simulation security series what
is the one to play as I is that mutation
as long as the computation so actually
I'm still processing the because powder
ball and because compact are you with
this security notion is a degeneration
of puncture Belial yeah exactly because
we had a cross here therefore we will
have across here okay and as you will
also see that there is a nice difference
between circuit and Tony Muslim because
for Stark a punk sharable iOS exists
because it's the same as I 0 itself
whereas a for tuning machine they cannot
exist assuming just one wave function it
is always the CLS and use it
spice I think I can in the if I assume I
oh I don't know if i can if i don't see
my own okay whether i can replace the
saris with a random Oracle so basically
the service is a US I guess yeah i also
dislike
so we so this the first result that I Oh
obfuscation implies weekend security a
factory that something that you already
showed and I just liked or was it it's
just a very true it's a very trivial
observation i can tell you afterwards
yeah is a serious Cespedes longest
imputation because otherwise no I think
in the random Oracle mother if I assume
I oh I can make this your ass as long as
the output precisely the length of the
output no none no more ago i'm just
saying he's as he is a petite him to crs
just to be as long as a computation no I
don't know I yeah I think Vinod can
answer this question basically the
surest is the secret key of the
functional encryption so can we make the
function encryption secret key shorter
than the the computation time yeah okay
yeah then
alright so I need to move on so they're
basically two ways to recommend to the
impossibility one is to leave the plane
model assume as your ass yes we can do
that the other way that impossibility
rules out for general distributions
nonetheless in applications we can still
hope that maybe certain application only
require the security to hold for some
specific nice distribution actually both
options of for circumventing the
impossibility that will be very useful
for us in our camp of going back from
one time used to multiple time use to
assume some exponential function but
actually show that this randomized
encoding in the series model number the
less is very powerful already and itself
could imply i owe for circuit or for
bounded lands bounded input tool emotion
and if we're willing to assume something
a little bit more which is still inside
the plane model but compared to the
randomized encoding for some very nice
distribution which i will tell you about
later now we can actually go one step
further to even fast get into remission
with unbounded inputs lines and closely
related with our result is the two
recent work by natick and prevention as
well as a V naught and near where they
show the functional encryption implies
aisle and if you still remember in the
previous slide and said that functional
encryption will give us argue in the crs
model therefore you put theorem 2 and
theorems three together it basically
give an alternative proof to the result
but we consider our proved to be simpler
you're all gonna be our judges and the
second i want to point out that already
in abhishek and the probe on jones work
they considered the compact are you and
in fact by a very simple combination we
can turn a compact RG into a functional
encryption using algebra ii well let me
say that exist actually we already know
that we can go for a long time use to
multiple time use through the route of
functional encryption however I consider
our work our our proof I believe somehow
brings more insight into the relation
between those two without going through
this complete not so complicated but
still more complex notion of functional
encryption in addition I just for the
second bullet a that I often Banda
important emotion was previously
constructed under strong extractability
assumption namely public on the aisle
and the public hoeing snarks and this is
kind of the first work that we do not
need to assume kind of extractability
assumption all right you're worried
about we have candidates for battery and
Cal w KO w LW will give a current like
gives a candidate for compact re it's a
nice distribution I'm gonna tell you in
more detail they turn yeah wait recruits
up sir so it gives the candidate for
compact re which is which assuming i 0
for circuits wait you said it's a
candidate I don't know how to prove it
yes yes there are three four candidates
italia candidate anticipated this
question okay so in the next I'm going
to try to first to tell you about this
nice relation between one time using
multiple time use and in particular to
make my life simpler I'm going to prove
to you something much more weaker than
the full power of the theorem which says
that it ignored the impossibility read
out for a second suppose that I really
have compact re in the plane model can I
get I owe for some bounded lands input
to emotion embed lines yeah
the result for one from a fee to compact
of opinion re do you need public ERP or
the secretiveness efficient
I have to think about it right now we
use the public key hmm all right but I
know where you're coming from i talked
alright so already to prove this
proposition it's not obvious why because
it still follows from this paradigm from
one time used to multiple time use for
something much weaker to something much
stronger but this is not the first time
that we encounter this in cryptography
why because we've already done this
before we know how to construct a PRF
from a PRG where one is multiple moulton
use the other one is one time okay and
in particular there is a very nice
correspondence in terms of compactness
why because the prg the seed is compact
independent of the length of the
expanded pseudo random output how did
how did the GTM do that well by trees so
this is where we're going to try to
mimic by trees so think about a tree in
order to a fast kturtle emotion m i'm
going to create this virtual tree which
is something in the mind that has depth
the same as the length of the input and
we're going to associate with each node
industry a randomized encoding an
encoding of some computation let me tell
you what they are look at the leaves
each of the leaf has an index
corresponding to precisely one input for
one leaf it's randomized encoding is
going to be encoding the Turing machine
itself together with the input
corresponding to the leaf what that
means is that if i evaluate this
encoding our get the output of the
computation on that particular input ok
great how about the internal node let me
look at one note you that has child the
vienna w this note is going to have a
randomized encoding of some function
they satisfy that when I evaluates this
encoding it's going to generate the
encoding of the true chosen
if you care about knowing what their
function is basically this function is
going to be recursively defined where
the function is going to run the
randomized encoding algorithm encoding
the function corresponding to its
children using some PRF random string
that's it and this we defined a
randomized encoding for every node in
the tree our alpha station is simply
going to bid encoding for the root the
root encoding the first thing to notice
is that well this sophistication is very
compact why because our he is compact
it's very strong it's always pretty
normal sizes so in the end the root is
also prone on your size how do I
evaluate well exactly we mimic the PRF
construction if I want to evaluate an
input X I'm going to take my routine
coding and evaluate to get is two
children and a minor it again basically
I value it's every encoding on the path
going to the input X and eventually I
evaluate the leaf encoding that will
produce me the output so what is the
base of the induction and confused so
this base I mean you cannot compute
right so let me just go to the what do
you mean a base I cannot compute you
find something the constable is it has
to be a base of the base the base of
this the base is the computation of the
vascular problem itself evaluates the
almost specific input ose sequences yeah
the base is defined
okay how about security well security in
order to show security we want to show
that if we're considering two machines
that are functionally equivalent I want
to show that the office kitchen which
are basically the route encoding course
money to those two machines are
indistinguishable and I'm gonna give a
proof by induction a long way to do that
and my induction hypothesis is that
encoding everything coding on a
particular layer at the bottom on layers
at the bottom are indistinguishable so
does the security go and start by
examining the leaves and then look at
the one particular note in the leaf well
notice that no matter it's a encoding
corresponding to m1 or m2 see someone
enemy two are functionally equivalent
they have the same output or input X
therefore this encoding corresponding to
two computation with identical output
and definitely they're going to be
indistinguishable once I have that I go
up the layers not backwards and if I
look at one note at the upper layer I've
already proven that the encoding at the
layer below which is the encoding of the
notes children are indistinguishable
there for now I crucially rely on the
distributional indistinguishability
security to conclude that the parent
encoding is also indistinguishable
that's it you can go up and up above
until you reach the root so if you don't
have Carly but something that's slightly
enclose you can still get something like
yeah so we can deal with sublunary I'd
it's in the next slide in the next of
yours Lydia and QED that's it okay and
it's a very simple proof all right so
the nice thing about looking at this
tree in particular is that it allows us
to lie kind of extended to the version
with unbounded inputs to Lee machine
really easily just like the
p r FG j MP RF tree how the goal here is
I want to not limit the length of the
info to the turning motion to be some
fixed end and I want to allow to
evaluate with arbitrary polynomial and
input just like up to emotion without
any security and to do that we're going
to thinking about a virtual tree now has
even extended length the depths which is
some super polynomial and now if I want
to evaluate the particular polynomial
lines input it's going to land in some
internal nodes in my tree instead of a
leaf am I going to to evaluate you by
evaluating the encoding or along the
path the leading to the node X but so
far it's not good why because even if i
get the encoding for x I don't get
anything from the previous construction
because all that god is to be able to
get the encoding of its children but
this can be easily fixed by changing the
encoding and x to compute something
additional which is itself an encoding
that allows us to actually evaluate an
emotional input X in other words now my
tree is going to look something like
this it's going to become a trinary tree
where each of them know that we're have
a dangling leaf which corresponding to
and encoding the ends okay so it's not
like a Christmas tree with some
ornaments on it this is all very nice i
like it very much except one yeah I'm
toughest game soon
super poly right and the time to first
gate is still pulling because i only
need to compute the routine coding
there's some technicality one needs to
handle but i don't want to go into the
detail here okay but that's all kind of
a dream because after all right showed
you there's no compact are you in
general so what do we say here okay so
we have two ways out of the
impossibility that one is going to the
series model if you want to go to the
series model it's really easy to fix the
proof which is we're going to publish a
crs for each of the layer and now my
ification is going to include both the
roots encoding together or the CR esas
and if you enter plugging our
construction of re in the series model
you really see a corresponding one to
one with the construction of Peavy and
aj and additionally as the Bene was
pointing out that i don't really need
the encoding stubbe sø so compact and in
fact the sub linear compact is enough
except i lose a little bit i won't get I
offertory motion but i will get I all
four circuits and this is without loss
of a generate generality by KL w14 that
they were still giving back I also
bounded input to emergency physician
okay however this method is never going
to extend the two unbounded input a
fascination why because I mean I have to
publish a series for each layer so when
the number of layers is super polynomial
as our nice the Christmas tree then I
can't deal with your ass yeah previous
slide with the series those are like the
secret keys and how corresponds to the
other construction don't use the
crickets at your work we're actually the
public keys edgy so you are asking how
do does this year is associated with the
encoding so the encoding algorithm is
going to use some public he associated
with the CRS you can think about the
series as a very long string together
with a public key
response to the constructions of
rejected an Egyptian everybody else so
in the fam when i plug in the functional
encryption construction is going to
corresponding to the public key of the
functional encryption together with the
secret key for some function yeah it's
going to be precisely so quickly like
how they defined it yeah use this to get
io for bounded input during machines do
you still need complexity visiting we
are sort of using complex than a virgin
when we did the induction for the proof
right
okay so how do we get around that while
the cubes oration here is that to enable
this paradigm I'm really looking at the
program that we are computing encoding
for I really found some very specific
distribution which are quite nice what
they are either at the leaf where the
leaf where encoding programs that are
functionally equivalent truly functional
equivalent or we are at some internal
node where we're encoding some function
which computes basically encoding of
encodings of encodings of encodings
recursively of some machine which are
truly functionally equivalent and
therefore this sum up together to our 0m
three that are in serious give us I of a
bounded input your emotion and are you
for some nice trip distribution give me
I 04 unbounded input to the motion okay
so how am i doing with respect to time
I'm coming it's over ok so I can skip to
the impossibility readouts and now we
can do one Tom 13 so five minutes are
you sure ok fine let's know it's time
okay all right let me tell you briefly I
mean I guess I'm create enough suspense
that this is something nice and why
would it be impossible ok alright so the
impossibility says just assume Huawei
function I can actually move out
sublinear re just argue that's a
slightly compressing of its output so
we're going to prove this using two
steps in the first step I'm going to see
my function is something else which is
IO for circuit and assume that i can
already rule out something your RT well
the nice thing is that already I have
proven through you in theorem Sri dance
when your arm yourself implies i owe
four circuits so as I have nicely
aligned to those two lines you combine
them together you will see that I don't
really need the assumption of Io for
circuit so just assume one-way function
we can rule out discipline your re ok so
let me now focus on step one so recorder
to show that there is no general
sublinear you recall what is the
security definition what I want is that
if I have outputs from of machines from
some distribution their outputs are in
the sink indistinguishable then I want
their encodings to be indistinguishable
so to create an impossibility read out
what I want to do is that I want to
create those distributions such that
their outputs are indistinguishable
however during encoding no matter what
sublinear randomized encoding algorithm
you're using are just blatantly
distinguishable I can do that then I'm
done and I'm going to do that assuming I
all our construction is going to for now
forget about input I just think about
the missions that always take only input
0 I create two distributions of those
machines and they were have some pseudo
random seed hard-coded inside SNK and
what do those motion do the Machine and
B is going to produce two things in its
output 1 is the expanded pseudo random
string and the other is the iof ask
asian of some program one of this
program know this program basically
verifies whether this pseudo random
string Y has low kamagra of complexity
it means that is going to take an input
and it checks whether this input is a
short and expands to Y if that's the
case it's going to output something
meaningful which is B if it's not this
as like I'm not meaningful but as you
can see the observation is that if we
have if if someone gets the output okay
and if that person has a short
representation of Y then he can really
run this a fascination to recover be and
therefore he can distinguish one of
these output is produced by m0 or m1 and
in fact this small s the only thing that
you can do in order to distinguish those
output distributions so this is kind of
equivalent to each other now our job is
basically done look at these two
distributions of machines if someone is
only getting the output because the Y is
a pseudo random string you should be
really hard to find a short
representation for it therefore it will
be hard to recover be or to distinguish
therefore output distribution are
indistinguishable if someone gets a
randomized encoding the story is
different because this adversary can
first evaluate the randomized encoding
to get the output and now nicely the
encoding itself it is a short
representation of Y therefore you can
just around this a physician Wednesday
encoding itself as the input to recover
be and distinguish and that's proof
think I don't need the full six minute
and that's small s all i want to say use
the suffix pollution so i use the suffix
menasha one-way function in order to say
so this the the counter example i just
show the use i owe our eventual result
does not rely on aisle the reason is
that we sub exponential on my function i
can go from yeah so in conclusion that i
hope i convince to you that this output
compressing randomized encoding is
highly related with sophistication
itself if you think about it as the
vicar was pointing out already that it's
really kind of very similar why because
here i have an encoding they expand out
to a very long output on the other hand
what's the fascination I have an
encoding of a machine they expand out to
the entire truth table of the function
with some input so do really similar
things and somehow we're saying that
even though this is much weaker because
the entire string is polynomial NC and
they didn't take any input in particular
still nevertheless you can go back to
investigation you can do so either
through the notion of functional
encryption by the paper of AJ and the BB
or you can go and actually directly just
using a tree very simple and in some
sense that that tells us if we want to
get a vacation we have to come up with
ways to encode our computation shorter
than its output thank you legends we
just high level of hell inaudible it's
about the Sierras I mean I can kind of
seemingly how long serious help you put
into Sarah's so short can features
included as part of your on the rise in
the audience is not short the serious is
a trail on oh I see sure you so I guess
the Sierras can be as long as the out
Poland can only grow that with what
result but length so I could compression
below a pool and say something with them
too it seems like a barrier line
complexity she don't count as a lens but
the spanner feels askari that's that's
cheating that's right you can move that
way oh this program
hey let's thank